bonjour merci de nous rejoindre dans fil
Eco l'émission qui revient sur
l'actualité économique locale on
commence tout de suite avec les titres
de cette édition
exporter en Asie une perspective
d'avenir pour les entreprises illinoises
à l'occasion de la 8e édition fête de
l'international la Chambre de Commerce
et l'Industrie de Versailles encourage
les entreprises du département à se
lancer dans l'aventure
pour le Mois de l'économie sociale et
solidaire la ville de La Verrière a
organisé un forum emploi une manière
d'informer les jeunes sur les métiers de
cette économie c'est à Versailles que
Caroline Sauvestre a installé son
showroom elle participe au concours
créatrice d'avenir et présente ses
produits bijoux et accessoires fait main
ils sont réalisés en Amérique latine
dans le respect du commerce équitable
enfin dans notre entretien cette semaine
nous parlerons de la colère des
entreprises yvesinoises les patrons de
PME et TPE s'apprêtent à descendre dans
la rue vous aborderons ce sujet avec
Alain Gosset bonjour vous êtes le
secrétaire de la CGPME des Yvelines nous
parlerons avec vous de la situation
actuelle des entreprises et des
revendications de celle-ci mais avant
cela passons en revue l'actualité de la
cette semaine les différentes chambres
de commerce et d'industrie francilienne
mettent l'international à l'honneur à
Versailles évènement fête de
l'international faite de l'international
pardon cible le continent asiatique au
programme de cette huitième édition des
experts des conseils et des réunions
d'information le but encourager les
entreprises divinoises à se lancer dans
l'export un reportage réalisé avec
William elle
jeunes entrepreneurs ou Dirigeants de
PME l'Asie les fait rêver la plupart de
ses chefs d'entreprise sont venus en
apprendre plus avant de se lancer dans
l'export Mathieu despenoux et PDG de la
société Cocktail Games il vient partager
son expérience en 2012 il s'est associé
avec un partenaire coréen pour exporter
ces jeux de société
l'administrativement c'est extrêmement
simple de créer une société en Corée du
Sud beaucoup plus qu'en France donc
voilà les choses se font se font
simplement assez rapidement voilà après
il faut être avec des gens de confiance
parce que vous signez des contrats en
anglais traduits en coréen en fait donc
et puis après pour travailler en fait à
distance il y a un truc qui s'appelle
Skype qui marche très bien donc on fait
ça assez régulièrement le bilan est
positif pour cette petite entreprise
elle compte même développer son activité
en Corée le continent asiatique
représente un marché qui prend de
l'ampleur les exportations des
entreprises yesinoises en Asie sont
passées de 1,1 milliard d'euros en 2011
à 1,36 milliards d'euros en 2013 la
Chine est en troisième place des pays
d'exportation après l'Allemagne et le
Royaume-Uni pourtant nombre
d'entreprises s'imaginent de se lancer
dans l'export est une aventure
périlleuse faire du business avec des
gens qui parlent pas à votre langue qui
n'ont pas la même culture dont les
besoins peuvent être mal définis c'est
pas aussi facile en tout cas ce n'est
pas un pas que l'on franchit
naturellement mais une fois ce premier
pas voir le deuxième réalisé je peux
vous dire l'entreprise export depuis 20
ans maintenant ça devient une mécanique
et les perspectives d'avenir sont
nombreuses dans les Yvelines les
exportations des entreprises ont atteint
9,25 milliards d'euros en 2013 le
département représente ainsi 12% des
exportations franciliennes soit 2,1% des
exportations nationales
et la Chambre de commerce et d'industrie
de Versailles ville a profité de cet
événement pour lancer son réseau plateau
à l'international 18 sociétés et trois
coachs des cadres de grandes entreprises
font partie de l'aventure écoutez ces
précisions de Brigitte sales
responsables des réseaux entreprises à
la CCI de Versailles Yvelines
ces entreprises vont se rencontrer une
fois par mois
la petite différence c'est qu'ils ne
vont aborder là que des sujets autour de
l'international mais des sujets qu'ils
auront choisi au préalable en tout début
de programme donc ce matin ils ont fait
connaissance et ils ont déjà d'ores et
déjà choisi des thématiques sur lequel
ils vont les premières thématiques sur
lesquelles ils vont ils vont vouloir
travailler
cette semaine s'achève le Mois de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et oui
c'était au mois de novembre à La
Verrière la ville a décidé de s'adresser
aux jeunes avec un forum emploi sur les
métiers de l'économie sociale et
solidaire Mélanie poquet Elodie moine
c'est recruteurs sont des représentants
d'entreprises mais aussi des
associations ou des coopératives à la
recherche de jeunes recrues à La
Verrière une douzaine d'entreprises de
partenaires étaient présents objectifs
sensibiliser les jeunes à l'économie
sociale et solidaire et parler des
emplois proposés par le secteur nous
avons la possibilité d'offrir des
emplois divers
qualifiés et nous permettant nous
permettons aussi à nos employés de
pouvoir évoluer à l'intérieur du groupe
ça recrute mais aussi il y a aussi
certaines méfiance vis-à-vis aussi des
entreprises donc c'est aussi pouvoir
montrer aux entreprises que avec le
social et l'insertion on peut aussi
avancer ensemble et faire de belles
choses avoir de très beaux parcours et
de réussite selon l'Observatoire
Régional de l'économie sociale et
solidaire en Île-de-France cette
économie en plein essor emploi près de
33000 personnes dans les Yvelines
pourtant les moins de 25 ans ne
représentent que 7% de ces salariés Paul
veut travailler dans le développement
durable et Traoré dans le domaine de
l'électricité ils ont tous les deux
passé plusieurs entretiens
des recruteurs et ils ont dit que le CV
il était bien donc j'attends la réponse
on a vu pour l'année 2015 la création de
postes sur l'emploi aidé et donc là plus
orienté sur le thème du développement
durable donc un peu plus adapté à mon
profil ils vont décider ça en interne
durant le mois de décembre début janvier
et donc je me retournerai vers eux à ce
moment là où il y aurait des réponses
concrètes finances action associative
santé de nombreuses activités de
l'économie sociale et solidaire propose
des emplois dans les Yvelines le taux de
chômage chez les jeunes de catégories A
s'élèvent à 15%
et nous restons sur le chômage des
jeunes dans les Yvelines un bilan de
l'année 2013 a été dressé par le préfet
le chômage dans les Yvelines et de 7,2%
un taux globalement inférieur à celui de
la France métropolitaine mais chez les
jeunes vous l'avez vu dans le sujet
précédent ce taux est de 15% et près
d'un jeune sur 4 et non qualifié dans
notre département il faut souligner
pourtant que 1934 emplois d'avenir ont
été signés depuis l'entrée en vigueur du
dispositif en 2012 37% de ses emplois
sont occupés par des jeunes
issus de zones sensibles urbaines avec
environ 10000 apprentis formés dans les
23 CFA du département les effectifs
d'apprentis des Yvelines sont en baisse
de 3% par rapport à 2012
emploie toujours une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle pour le secteur
automobile dans les Yvelines le site
Renault de Flins-sur-Seine va embaucher
environ 450 intérimaires pour mettre en
place provisoirement une équipe de nuit
en 2015 le comité de direction de
Renault l'a annoncé mardi le recrutement
devrait avoir lieu entre le mois de
février et de mars du côté de PSA à
Poissy les informations sont bien moins
positives lundi le constructeur a
annoncé 2450 départs de ces usines
françaises selon la CGT près de 700
emplois en contrat à durée indéterminée
pourraient être supprimé en 2015 dans
l'usine de Poissy à Poissy l'usine de
PSA emploie je le rappelle
5549 salariés
à gazerons les travaux d'aménagement du
futur centre commercial ont démarré dans
la zone d'activités de bel-air-la-forêt
ce projet a été lancé il y a 4 ans le
futur centre s'étendra sur 35000 m² de
terrain et comprendra 12500 m² de
bâtiments qui accueilleront 16 enseignes
ce nouveau centre commercial s'appellera
le beffrin contraction de la route de
Bray et de la rue d'orfin il pourrait
être livré dès le mois de juin 2015
de la semaine
cette semaine nous allons parler des
petites et moyennes entreprises
ivinoises qui appellent à manifester
nous sommes je le rappelle avec Alain
Gosset secrétaire général de la CGPME
des Yvelines donc la Confédération
générale des petites et moyennes
entreprises alors tout d'abord les
entreprises dans la rue qui manifestent
c'est une première non on a arrêté dans
la rue pour les 35 heures et donc mais
c'est une première quand même oui c'est
je crois que ça ça montre qu'on a un
certain ras-le-bol et que il faut pour
se faire entendre aller dans la rue
c'est peut-être dommage d'ailleurs alors
d'habitude vous aviez peut-être plus
enfin l'habitude de parler avec les
acteurs économiques au gouvernement vous
décidez de manifester c'est quand même
un acte fort quels sont vos
revendications
je crois déjà c'est un ras-le-bol
général par rapport à la situation
économique je crois que nos adhérents
sont découragés par leur baisse de
trésorerie leur baisse de chiffre
d'affaires l'augmentation des mares la
baisse des marges l'augmentation des
taxes etc la complexité des normes et
donc je crois que c'est un ras-le-bol
général on a aussi l'impression c'est
que
toutes les réformes sont pliées à
l'avance et qu'on travaille dans la
margénalité et donc on a envie de
s'entendre parce qu'on a envie de se
faire entendre dans la rue tout
simplement pour défendre certaines de
nos positions alors justement trois
réformes sont sont vraiment décrié par
la CGPME donc le compte pénibilité la
l'obligation d'information des salariés
avant toute sessions d'entreprises et le
plafonnement du temps partiel à 24
heures alors qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
me dire voilà sur ces réformes
qu'entendez-vous dire de la part des
entreprises des Yvelines
on va avoir une simplification du
bulletin de paie
chose qui est je pense assez simple très
bon pour les entreprises et en même
temps on va nous demander à gérer le
compte pénibilité qui ingérable donc
d'un côté on donne une simplification de
l'autre on augmente la complexité c'est
dans tous les domaines on arrive à se
phénomène on essaie de simplifier
quelque chose pour complexifier d'autres
choses donc compte pénibilité pour nous
pourquoi on n'est pas d'accord mais
entendu on reconnaît qu'il y a de la
pénibilité et certaines branches dans
leur domaine essaient de gérer cette
pénilité ce qu'on ne veut pas c'est
d'avoir un système très complexe qu'on
ne peut pas gérer en tant que chef
d'entreprise nous sommes des TPE PME
donc entre deux cinq dix personnes et 15
personnes et certaines dispositions du
compte pénibilité sont totalement
ingérables et donc on sera hors la loi
et sur l'obligation d'information des
salariés avant toutes ces entreprises là
on a peut-être un peu du mal nous à
s'imaginer le problème là aussi c'est
moi je pense que c'est parti d'un bon
geste d'informer ses salariés la seule
chose c'est que dans la réalité une
session d'entreprise pour une TPE PME se
fait je dirais dans une certaine cercle
privé pour que ça fonctionne c'est une
mayonnaise qui peut se casser à la
dernière minute
pourquoi tout simplement parce que c'est
un sorte de mariage de contrat de
mariage entre le vendeur et le et celui
qui va racheter jusqu'au bout jusqu'à la
signature et au paiement il y a des
choses qui peuvent finalement casser la
signature le fait de devoir informer de
moi au préalable et salarié ça peut
mettre des problèmes dans ces rouages
qui font que la vente se frappe et
l'autre détriment finalement des
salariés puisque une vente qui ne se
fait pas quelquefois malheureusement de
moi trois mois un an ou deux ans plus
tard la société s'arrête alors
j'aimerais aussi qu'on explique un petit
peu aux téléspectateurs le plafonnement
du temps partiel à 24 heures pourquoi
cela pose un problème aux entreprises
c'est une c'est une la bonne volonté
c'est de je crois que de demander à
avoir un train de travail de 24 heures
c'est bien d'un côté mais d'un autre
côté ça va pénaliser les emplois non
qualifiés dans le SCP par exemple dans
le service à la personne pour pour
pouvoir suivre quelqu'un qui qui a une
personne âgée où on apporte un repas à
18h malheureusement il nous faut un
nombre important personnel où on ne peut
pas donner 24 heures donc là aussi ça va
mettre en péril des emplois des
entreprises et d'une peut-être une bonne
idée sur la base on devient un système
complexe impossible à gérer et contraire
finalement à l'intérêt de l'entreprise
et de ses salariés mais si vous
manifestez justement contre ces réformes
au moment où elles ont été votées où
elles ont été décidées il n'y a pas eu
de dialogue social entre justement vous
vos représentants et le gouvernement
comme on arrive à cette situation de
crise maintenant bien sûr qu'il y a eu
un dialogue un certain dialogue c'est un
pack de responsabilité on a signé le
pack mais grosso modo on a eu très peu
de choses et dans les promesses et
aujourd'hui on se dit ras-le-bol et donc
il faut manifester pour s'entendre se
faire entendre
la situation est-elle plus compliquée
pour les patrons dans les Yvelines
est-ce que c'est un département
spécifique où la situation telle
nationale compliquée de façon nationale
vous avez cité des chiffres de l'emploi
ou malheureusement même si le taux de
chômage 7,2 et plus faible que la
moyenne nationale nous allons des
perspectives négatives pour le 2015-2016
dû à notre spécialisation
d'industrialisation de perte de notre
industrie et des services qui sont
autour donc on a besoin d'une profonde
de mutation donc c'est vrai que les
patrons des Yvelines
ou un moral assez bas et pour pouvoir
éventuellement se réindustrialiser il
faut aussi avoir des augmentations de
marge pour pouvoir investir dans le long
terme mais aussi pour pouvoir investir
il faut avoir une direction à long terme
du gouvernement et ce qu'on reproche
c'est les yoyo c'est on annonce quelque
chose deux heures après on le retire et
ça ça ne peut pas donner le moral au
chef d'entreprise pour embaucher il faut
du chiffre d'affaires certes mais aussi
du long terme de la vue à long terme
donc Manuel Valls qui dit j'aime
l'entreprise la nomination d'Emmanuel
Macron au final c'est pas des signals
qui vous ont peut-être sécurisé moi
quand je quand je parle de l'entreprise
j'ai l'impression qu'elle a division ne
parle que du CAC 40 ou des grosses
entreprises on oublie que les millions
d'emplois se font dans les petites
entreprises et j'ai l'impression que
quand Manu va se dit j'aime l'entreprise
il aime les entreprises du Medef il
n'aime pas les petites entreprises qui
font le tissu et la richesse de la
France qui font l'emploi et cette emploi
là il est pas délocalisé c'est du vrai
emploi alors justement en parlant du
Medef il ne se joint pas à vous pour
cette manifestation qui aura lieu je le
rappelle le lundi 1er décembre il se
joint à nous dans la semaine nous avons
tous des manifestations diverses
diverses formes donc on a une semaine où
nous sommes tous unis tous ensemble pour
pouvoir mobiliser les entrepreneurs par
contre ils ne se soigne pas je vois pas
à nous la manifestation tout simplement
parce que on est deux je dirais qu'on a
des vues un peu différentes sur certains
sujets et on a peut-être notre notre
image de petites moyennes entreprises
qui différencent du Medef on peut
descendre dans la rue il y a une
différence de traitement selon vous
entre les petites entreprises françaises
et les grosses entreprises qui
représentent un peu le Medef finalement
bien sûr qu'on parle du cice on s'est
malheureusement que une TPE a du mal à
faire un petit dossier pour récupérer la
somme qui lui était due par contre dans
une grosse entreprise ils ont toute une
technostructure qui permet de pouvoir
faire de traiter les dossiers et d'avoir
des mêmes qu'elles soient des effets de
Ben donc oui il y a des différences sur
certains points le mot d'ordre donc de
la manifestation de lundi et PME et TPE
cadenassé libéré nos entreprises est-ce
que vous allez vous enchaîner au gris du
ministère de Bercy iPhone
pour décanasser merci on veut pas être
attaché à Bercy on veut que Bercy nous
libère nos énergies vous pensez être
combien combien de parce qu'ils d'autres
syndicats vous ont vous ont rejoints
professionnelles qui nous ont rejoints
donc la CGP n'est pas seulement ce dans
ce lundi 1er décembre il faut quand même
donner la place peut-être on peut donner
lieu si on sait pas trop de la publicité
alors c'est à 10h place Félix Éboué dans
le 12e et donc on se finit tous là pour
aller vers Bercy à peu près 4000 entre
4500 et 5000 patrons sont prévus donc
lundi vous savez à peu près combien il y
aura de patrons ivinois qui seront
présents on a déjà on a mobilisé des
carres qui partent de Rambouillet de 50
ans et de et de Versailles et ensuite
comme on est quand même près de la
région parisienne on fait partie quand
même de la grande du Grand Paris etc
donc beaucoup de nos chers adhérents
vont venir directement donc oui on sera
nombreux on représentera au moins plus
de 10% des chiffres annoncés la suite un
petit peu de ces actions est-ce qu'il y
aura d'autres actions qui vont être
menées cette semaine ou la semaine
prochaine il y a des actions dans la
semaine fait par d'autres syndicats
parce qu'on est unis dans la dans
l'action de la semaine et par contre les
actions de la cgge dépendra bien entendu
si on est écouté ou pas
et bien nous verrons ça nous vous
suivrons d'ailleurs lundi nos caméras
seront présentes pour aller assister à
cette manifestation merci Alain Gosset
sur notre plateau donc poursuivons notre
émission avec le chiffre de la semaine
880 c'est le nombre d'entreprises qui
ont travaillé au sein des réseaux
plateaux depuis sa création en 2001 pour
rappel le réseau plateau un réseau de
partage entre petites et grandes
entreprises est né dans les Yvelines il
est aujourd'hui largement développé dans
toute la France 153 grandes entreprises
ont également participé à l'aventure
depuis ses débuts aujourd'hui dans le
département 300 dirigeants et 53 cadres
coachs de grandes entreprises
travaillent au sein du réseau plateau
et nous poursuivons notre émission avec
l'entreprise de la semaine
l'entreprise de la semaine est originale
je dirais même atypique oui atypique ça
tombe bien car c'est le nom de cette
marque versaillaise elle propose des
bijoux et accessoires fait main issus du
commerce équitable Caroline sobestre à
la tête de cette marque a également
décidé de participer au concours
créatrice d'avenir organisé par France
Active voici son portrait pardon réalisé
avec William hell et Romain russefini
des vitrines colorées et gay la nuit
noire cette petite boutique apparaît
comme atypique dans les rues des
artisans d'art à Versailles à
l'intérieur des accessoires et bijoux
tous faits mains Caroline Sauvestre les
Décines jusqu'ici rien d'extravagant
leur particularité tous ces produits
sont confectionnés en Amérique latine
par des tribus ou ethnies minoritaires
voyage 2 à 3 fois par an en Amérique
latine et je trouve les ateliers comme
ça c'est toute une question de
relationnel en fait quand vous
connaissez déjà un artisan ou un
producteur ou un groupe ethnique on vous
envoie forcément vers un autre etc etc
la marque de Caroline respecte les
principes du commerce équitable tout est
réalisé à la main les matières premières
sont naturelles même les colorants
utilisés sont respectueux de
l'environnement les artisans locaux sont
rémunérés correctement ils travaillent
tous dans de petits ateliers ou
directement de chez eux les bijoux je
les dessine après j'envoie les dessins
en Colombie quand les pièces sont prêtes
je vais à l'atelier sur place et on fait
le montage ensemble voir si les colliers
tombent bien à la base de ces bijoux
justement l'ivoire végétal la graine
allégée latineuse à la base on peut la
boire donc quand on tranche ça en mal
avec la machette en forêt on peut la
boire ça va pas de goût du tout et puis
on la laisse sécher entière
au sol pendant près d'un mois et elle se
solidifie et elle devient plus dense que
du bois auparavant Caroline travaillait
dans le secteur du tourisme elle s'est
lancée dans l'entrepreneuriat en 2011 en
rachetant cette marque créée par son
frère il y a 8 ans une aventure
enrichissante mais pas toujours facile
les difficultés c'est notamment pas
d'internet pour les ethnies donc il faut
téléphoner quand le réseau fonctionne
elle si elle doivent recevoir des choses
par Internet il faut les envoyer dans un
village à quelqu'un qui va leur sortir
l'imprimer leur donner il n'y a pas
d'unité de mesure avec les ethnies donc
c'est pareil quand on donne des tailles
c'est assez compliqué de tout se fait
sur tradition orale l'engouement des
débuts pour le commerce équitable tant à
s'affaiblir avec la crise afin de
trouver d'autres sources de financement
Caroline a décidé de participer au
concours créatrice d'avenir organisé par
France Active j'ai très peu de portes
ouvertes pour justement passer des
concours ou bénéficier de subventions de
choses comme ça de par l'ancienneté de
l'entreprise je me suis dit pourquoi pas
ça fait un petit challenge aussi ça
permet de se remettre en question en
France aujourd'hui la création
d'entreprise par des femmes ça reste
encore comme dans d'autres secteurs de
la société assez en retrait par rapport
à un public masculin aujourd'hui à peu
près 30% de femmes créent des
entreprises c'est le cas en
Île-de-France donc on n'est pas sur une
parité l'objectif du concours c'est de
permettre de faire progresser la
création d'entreprise par des femmes et
de faire en sorte que plus de femmes
s'impliquent dans la création
d'entreprise créatrice d'avenir propose
cinq prix de 5000 euros chacun dans des
catégories différentes une aide non
négligeable pour Caroline cette année
son chiffre d'affaires devrait avoisiner
les 70 000 euros elle en reversera une
partie un orphelinat de Bogota qu'elle
soutient depuis 2006
de l'entreprise de la semaine au métier
il n'y a qu'un pas passons maintenant au
métier de la semaine
pas un mais deux métiers cette semaine
et ils sont presque complémentaires je
vous parle des métiers du chiffre
expert-comptable commissaire aux comptes
il représente 250 000 emplois en France
dans les Yvelines la profession
cherchent à séduire les jeunes car vous
allez le voir le métier recrute 10000
personnes sont attendues dans les
prochaines années à venir c'est ce qu'on
découvert Patrick Jacques de Dixmude et
Anthony Rech
500 lisseur rassemblé au Théâtre du
Chesnay pas d'acteurs présents ni de
star mondialement connu ce sont ses
experts-comptables et commissaires aux
comptes qu'ils sont venus voir les
métiers du chiffre certains s'y
intéressent déjà d'autres les découvrent
des débouchés etc et du coup j'ai un peu
je commence à découvrir avec tous les
témoignages qu'on a et j'aime bien
manier un peu les nombres et communiquer
avec les gens je voulais pas rester dans
un bureau ou des choses comme ça et du
coup oui enfin pour moi ça c'est
intéressant
histoire d'avoir une idée de quoi faire
après le BTS et
et après voilà avoir des idées un peu
plus claires sur
comptable les métiers de comptable etc
après je sais pas encore ce que je vais
faire dans les Yvelines depuis de
nombreuses années la profession ne
séduit pas suffisamment les jeunes
pourtant la demande existe par les temps
qui courent un peu délicat de se dire on
arrive pas à recruter alors qu'il y a
quand même un taux de chômage assez
important on s'est dit bah il faut aller
leur voir les gens leur montrer ce que
ce que c'est que notre métier pour
effectivement qu'ils puissent venir dans
nos filières de manière plus naturelle
l'expert comptable ne se contente pas de
tenir précisément les contes annuels
d'une société il les conseille et
favorise leur développement ses
connaissances juridiques lui permettent
aussi d'accompagner les créations
d'entreprises 90% des experts-comptables
sont aussi commissaires aux comptes on
est commissaire aux comptes de la
société on est désigné pour 6 ans en
principe
et pendant donc six ans on est on est
chargé de vérifier les comptes de cette
société et de de
les certifier c'est à dire que on
certifie que les comptes sont
sincère et représente l'image fidèle des
opérations de la société après un
diplôme de comptable en gestion puis une
formation de type master Marie effectue
son stage dans ce cabinet d'une durée de
trois ans il est obligatoire et permet
d'appréhender les différentes facettes
du métier le côté à la fois
réflexion théorie sol dans le bureau et
le côté relation clientèle puis
également un troisième côté qui
m'attirait enfin qui était le côté
documentation actualités être au coeur
de l'information Marie a un contrat en
CDI elle gagne environ 30 000 euros par
an le salaire moyen d'un comptable
distagiaire elle n'a pas eu de
difficultés à trouver un employeur on
travaille pratiquement toujours avec des
collaborateurs jeunes et ça ça pousse
beaucoup à la fin de son stage elle
devra valider son mémoire un examen
difficile le taux de réussite avoisine
les 50%, mais le jeu en vaut la
chandelle chaque année plus de la moitié
des cabines français recrutent des
expert-comptables junior
nous arrivons à la fin notre émission et
cette information de dernière minute
vient de tomber les chiffres du chômage
dans les Yvelines le nombre de chômeurs
étant légère baisse moins 0,5% en un
mois à noter qu'en Île-de-France le
nombre de chômeurs a progressé de 5,2%
sur un an parce que maintenant à
l'agenda de la semaine
les métiers de la justice vous
intéressent si vous souhaitez vous
orienter vers une carrière d'avocat
d'huissier ou de juristes la Cité des
Métiers propose une réunion
d'information elle a lieu le mercredi du
mercredi 3 décembre de 14h30 à 16h à
trappe vous pourrez ainsi en savoir plus
sur ces métiers merci de nous avoir
suivi je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un prochain numéro de
Philippo je vous souhaite une très bonne
soirée